KKBOX was founded in 2004
We started using cloud technology
In order to provide the music broadcasting service legally
With the support of registration companies
Musicians
And partners in the music industry
We have become a major music supply application
Among online listeners
We believe that music makes our lives better
So we strive to provide
Best listening experience for music
So that music becomes affordable
Enjoyable and easily accessible
And affordable
And across various devices available
We offer the best music anytime, anywhere
We use Google Play Basic
To develop many new technologies
We have won many awards
In 2015, we won the "Best apps 2015" award from Google Play
And in 2016
We won the "Most Wanted" award from Google Play
The "Most Expensive" award
More than half of active KKBOX listeners
They are Android users
It was always Android
Axis development is important to us
Whether it's Android TV or Chromecast
Or Android Auto
Or even Android Wear
We are committed to studying and developing the product
So listeners can enjoy the best music experience across multiple systems
On all devices in our music service
In May of 2016
We started using billing within Google Play apps
This form of payment
Allow members
Complete the payment process
In a few simple steps
Being associated with custom messages
It increases the user's willingness to buy
Compare with other payment methods
The user can decide to buy faster, in half the normal time
It can also help speed up
Successful buyers referrals in KKBOX
We look forward to further development in this area
We entered the 2009 global market
By launching our services in Hong Kong
Japan, and Southeast Asia
Through in-app billing
We were able to get more flexibility
In the management of global trade operations
KKBOX will continue to improve
Products through improved content and features
And the technology of the Statute
Our partnership with Google Play allows us
Also provide service
Sophisticated and comfortable
To integrate with the entire music industry systems
So we can provide
More distinctive and versatile service
For music fans all over the world